[ __ ] get perspective we're so [ __ ]
lucky stop crying
I'm the biggest believer in humans in a
macro it's why we're still here
but in the micro it's hard for us to get
so excited to eliminate plastic straws
because Turtles get choked by that right
it's just hard or stop eating this thing
that's delicious in return for this
thing that's not delicious because in
400 years they'll be better for your
great lakes so what I would say is too
much ideology more practicality and more
short-term benefits are a very important
starting point so our model is if your
brands that does a commercial and it
cost eight hundred thousand dollars in
out-of-pocket and creative and
production we try to convince that
client to do six or five or four or
three long-form Facebook videos for that
same cost which can first fit different
demographics right because when you do
one commercial it's just vanilla whereas
you know if you if you star an Asian you
know family and their 20s and target
asian-american or Europeans in their 20s
you're gonna over index in relevance
housenki bound about to give this
keynote I'm shipping his head cuz we're
settling a bet 100 bucks for film 100
anniversary but right that being
couldn't find any
so we should yeah we don't we settle the
scores around here lights they come they
go with stock the show goes on and now
just wants a piece of fuzz we made a bet
to shave his head for a hundred bucks he
said when you get the Helsinki we will
uh we will take care of it so I'm gonna
pull out my hundred dollars I've never
shaved the man's head before so I hope
this doesn't hurt you good goal boy all
right I'm gonna I'm gonna do the first
cut then I'm gonna move you on over and
give the key no cuz that's what you're
here for but are you ready this is
[ __ ] awesome
some of the biggest things I'm pushing
right now is be very aggressive in your
20s and try a lot of things some people
are naturally self-aware and have a very
clear vision others are still trying to
figure it out I think the answer for the
if I can bring value to the most people
here is if you 100% conviction and you
know exactly what you're passionate
about and what you're good about well
then go but if you have any doubt early
on this is where you could take the most
risk right what most humans do is start
making money and then start creating
debt or overhead that puts them into a
box the beauty the beauty of being in
your 20s is you don't have money or
stuff often and so that allows you the
freedom to try [ __ ] and during them
you're like this trying [ __ ] around AI
or AR or crypto blockchain is a great
thing because you may stumble on your
passion and what you're good at
so both can work it comes down to the
individual vlogging is not going to stop
there's no reason for it to stop people
have an inherent need to communicate
it's who we are it's what we've done
forever drawing on caves smoke signals
writing we communicate so vlogging will
not is just beginning everybody will do
it where those videos are being consumed
will change through the years I think
the next three or four years is a
Facebook YouTube world and let me give
you one other piece of ice if you're
saying yourself [ __ ] then what do I do
you're never gonna know the alternative
if you go in all in on a project you're
never gonna be able to figure out if you
tried other things so this is more about
being optimistic or pessimistic as a
human being you know if in ten years if
you didn't try something else even if
you're successful and you're a pessimist
you're gonna make up in your own mind
then if you did something else it would
have been better so I think this is
about making a decision
not dwelling or pondering on what if
because what-ifs crippled people 99%
likely it won't happen but if your 1%
that's good enough to actually execute
and get to the place where you go global
then you get to go global
but nobody is global right away but
everybody looks at Facebook and uber
like uber started in just San Francisco
ubers so guys what we're spending a year
and a half just trying to figure out San
Francisco a year and a half
dinner sale yeah no it's not it's a long
time in the way that you're wired right
now yeah
a year and a half is nothing so when I
met you first time 2011 yes right after
that I founded my own agency yes and
what shop don't screw the rocks angular
I founded the agency I sold everything I
had and my apartment on eBay and today
we are twelve people and about 1 million
euro in revenues relations what's the
biggest mistake people do where they are
where I am now at this point yeah I
think they get impatient yeah it took
you all this time to get here now you
got this nice little Foundation and now
you're saying okay I'm gonna go from 1
million euros to five million 10 million
it's just the same old game it's no
different to Joanna like everybody's
mistake from the beginning to the end is
lack of patience and practicality
everybody wants things to fast like you
were able to get here the answer for you
to continue in a client service business
is more of the same but what happens is
people start getting loose when they
have money or when they're going in the
right direction
so I think you know I mean I I think the
thing that you need to continue to do is
continue to hone your craft and whatever
the agency does get more clients and
then also keep an eye on any technology
that can disrupt the other mistake
people make is for example in 2009 the
mistake that people made as a 1 mil
Belair agency was they they because they
made their million on Google they
disrespected Facebook got it so the the
there's two mistakes people make ones
offense ones defense you know going nice
and slow is defensive in some ways they
try to become a rabbit instead of a
turtle right and that's the mistake and
then number two they disrespect what's
happening around them so for me I never
play in the middle I'm very insular to
what I'm doing and then I'm paying
attention to the macro things that can
[ __ ] up what I'm doing and I respect
those energies if they're bigger than me
competitors are not bigger than me
platforms are bigger than me you
understand so I think those would be the
mistakes you might make you gotta bro
happy birthday thank you
I was talking to Chinese couple and the
male of the male-female duo asked a very
good question which I didn't really have
an answer for but it was it was how he's
approaching it from the largest
sovereign state in the world or whatever
it is right and there's 195 200 of these
and one global system so his question
was where or how does how does how does
a sovereign state with all its
institutions with all its you know
mechanisms in place effectively control
or or manage the tide of automation that
is on its way
well you know I think that I think that
we are under estimating our ability to
find new things for people to do I mean
everybody said that the farming was the
infrastructure to our society like you
know there was a time and age when
machines were invented that eliminated
farming jobs and everybody said that it
would ruin our world because everybody
was a [ __ ] farmer but then we did
other [ __ ]
for example David's career is to film
another human being and travel with him
this is not a career that I think a lot
of us knew existed 20 years ago so so I
think that I think that when people
start talking about at the a very heavy
[ __ ] like you're asking me which is what
happens when AI really hits scale and we
eliminate jobs driverless cars in
America truck driving is the number one
job in a like what happens they go find
to do something else
like this is what always happens like
there used to not like people used to
ride a horse and then a car was invented
but the man was a I was a horse person I
drove a horse to get people around
that's how I paid for my family's life
here's a car oh my god not oh my god you
did something else true entrepreneurs
don't cry about what they don't have
they focus on what they do have and so
if you're in the Ukraine and the rules
of the government and the eco system are
what they are you deal with it and you
know in the u.s. I'm an entrepreneur
that works 18 hours a day and have
sacrificed 20 years and I give up more
than half of my income to the government
to give to people who don't that's the
rules of America you play within the
rules of
your game so my biggest point of view on
humans analyzing humans is that we
underestimate us in parallel here's what
I think people who dwell on oh my god AI
is coming meanwhile so it's space
exploration
let's say space exploration works let's
say all of us here actually want to live
on the moon
let's just play you got much [ __ ] we
have to do up there like III think
there's enormous underestimation of the
human spirit
it's how I think about terrorism if
terrorism was as real as people think it
is there'd be a terrorist act with a car
driving through people in London Paris
and New York every day of the week it's
unstoppable it's unstoppable to stop
somebody from getting into a car wreck
and driving into a bunch of people we
underestimate how good the human spirit
is and how capable the human spirit is
since 1950 there's been a human that's
had the ability to blow up the whole
[ __ ] place I mean it so to answer your
question very easily because what humans
do not sovereign states is find other
[ __ ] to do so if you work in a [ __ ]
telemarketing station right now and AI
is gonna answer all those questions and
you're not gonna have a job anymore
you're gonna find a different job like
following somebody around with a camera
[Music]
we haven't done a solid airport Gary in
a while but it's warm here in Finland
oh-ho that I want
[Music]
so many of you that have but you're at a
crossroads and there's confusion in the
system it doesn't feel the way you
wanted to do something about it
the answer to every single thing running
through your dome right now is so so
what are you gonna do about it
because the reality is it's halftime and
halftime adjustments are sexy real good
[Music]
the to me buying and doing something to
get some money then going and buying
things that are under price and then
selling them and if we have technology
eBay Facebook marketplace Craigslist or
like at a flea market that is literally
something everybody on earth
we're live all right
what where's my [ __ ] where's my chat
gets ass got caught I need my [ __ ]
can you put you can you keep with the
chat where's the chat oh I know but what
about what is this I understand I feel
like I don't like like [ __ ] like that
[Music]
let's go [ __ ] how do you are I lived
that life
I lived in a whole time entire game I
don't know how to bury it my keepers
that nd [ __ ] tea
let's [ __ ] coat which come see me did
you separate out its which world with
one no the winners get gifts over here
so we presenting Garry with the trophy
you know he's blossoming in the world of
sick media social entrepreneurship this
is [ __ ] amazing
tell everybody what this is about this
is about that talent spongebob um
marijuana plant and oh you see this
spongebob has to be ah he's feeling
really good it's a collaboration about
myself and Ron English and made by
monsters so we have the hand-delivered
to Gary we got three different versions
I got the gold one yeah we got a gold
one break down the numbers this came out
sold out so gold sold out first and how
much let's run with this this how many
units it's 500 500 units and s-sir
sold out sold out and how much was this
650 all of them sold out if any black
can open the other ones for me so we've
got you got the whole set 650 on this
one you know and now other two is called
ganja grin gold and guys are gonna
silver so tell everybody about the
Charlie Brown because I think that
really established your foundation
voters yes the world I grew up looking
at cars
no african-american cartoon so I created
a black Charlie Brown figured he was
made him to different color ways one
black lone one was silver and oh it's
sold out of success we did 600 pieces
sold out of three minutes and this is
our third toy and this one is it's the
gold the ghosts are crazy this is crazy
he was that was the first one that good
sellout and how many of these were made
there was one one fit to each of these
and how much was this this all over 650
all 650 yeah and then this is the seller
so and he's called pot of gold he called
Silver Haze so come on everybody that's
watching twitch you know inhaling and
exhaling we're gonna leave it up
parental guy that was a good give and go
yeah let's go look at that big league
jumper snowbirds alright pop that three